welcome back to CBS mornings this
morning we're focusing on the spread of
illegal guns on American streets CBS
Evening News anchor and managing editor
Noah O'Donnell spent time with
Washington DC's Metropolitan Police
Department to see the challenge up close
to understand the big issues facing law
enforcement Nationwide she also visited
the ATF lab in our nation's capital and
learned the guns that police are
encountering are more dangerous than
ever
this is what a nine millimeter pistol
sounds like modified and set to fully
automatic with an illegal conversion
device
is so these are actually referred to as
machine gun conversion devices you can
see some of these are mass-produced
metallic made and this is what you'll
hear referred to as a switch what do you
know about where these are coming from a
lot of those can be made with anyone
with 3D printer these here are more
commercially produced you will notice
that a lot of these may carry the Glock
logo on the rear however they are not
associated with Glock whatsoever the
conversion devices are small and
inexpensive they cost as little as
twenty dollars but can change a handgun
to fire 15 rounds in under two seconds
you really kind of spraying bullets
absolutely especially out of a handgun
it's very hard to maintain a weapon that
small with that amount of fire at the
ATF lab in DC they're processing a
record number of illegal guns Commander
how often are you seeing these now we're
standing with a degree of regularity
about 50 percent more than we saw last
year and that's because it makes this
gun much more dangerous absolutely it
increases the likelihood that we're
going to encounter multiple victims when
these are used and also in those
singular victim incidents it increases
the likelihood that those incidents will
be fatal Commander Lachey Mako reports
to Chief of Police Robert Conte who was
just tapped to join the FBI a lot more
guns are in communities now a lot more
guns than what we experienced over the
course of my time here in the police
department we rode along with the chief
around the nation's capital to learn
about the challenges his officers are
facing with crime at alarming levels we
have the data right here from your
website about DC crime all crime up 25
percent murder up 24 motor vehicle theft
up
107 percent what's going on in our
nation's capital when you talk
specifically about the violent crime
early in this year we had a couple of
cases where we saw uh individuals just
shooting people shooting each other for
no reason individuals who were unable to
resolve disputes simple arguments that
turned into homicides why because people
have access to Illegal Firearms when
they have access to Illegal Firearms
they use them unfortunately back in the
lab they showed us how the device can
take a legal weapon from this
this
the ATF says they've seen a nearly 600
percent increase Nationwide of modified
weapons there have been more mass
shootings in America in 2023 than there
have been days
how much do you worry about a mass
shooting in D.C there's something that's
on my mind every day all right while
we're sitting here you take you know one
person with one firearm that's capable
of shooting you know 100 rounds of
ammunition at very rapidly in a short
period of time you know that can happen
anywhere at any point at any time we see
these inverter switches that are able to
convert semi-automatic Firearms into
fully automatic Firearms those are
things that keep me up at night for CBS
mornings I'm Nora O'Donnell in
Washington
it's a powerful interview there with the
outgoing chief of police in Washington
D.C Nora's interview with him that she
aired on the Evening News included two
other details on the rise in crime a
lack of recruiting or a struggle to
recruit new officers and also a lack of
prosecutions when the officers do make
arrests so some great reporting from
Nora in our nation's capital